[Music]
thank you
as animals we owe a lot to the
single-celled organisms that came before
us
these are the organisms that laid the
chemical groundwork for how we live from
the DNA and proteins within them to the
molecules they released into the
environment and eventually some of those
early single-celled organisms had an
evolutionary Epiphany that laid the
groundwork for multicellularity if they
banded together into a colony and worked
together blending their lives and
identities until the lines between them
began to blur then maybe they could
accomplish more together than they could
on their own
[Music]
there's something humbling about looking
at our hands or feet and Imagining the
mixture of cells within them and
realizing the lessons that keep those
cells bound together physically and
biologically are rooted in a very
ancient study in cooperation
and colonies persist to this day
single-celled organisms like Gnostic
link themselves together into chain-like
colonies that allow individual cells to
be assigned specific tasks like nitrogen
fixation that benefit the colony overall
but colonies aren't restricted to
single-celled organisms animals have
gotten in on this Behavior too stacking
their multicellular cells together for
the same reason the nostock does because
they can and because it's good for them
two particularly notable examples of
this are the colonies of Mossy bryozoa
found in waters throughout the world as
well as Coral that live in the ocean and
also as we've seen before in Coral Farms
but there's one animal Colony that's a
little bit unusual I don't of course
that animal is the rotiver
[Music]
to be fair to rotifers this is not a
typical behavior for all of them
there are more than 2 000 species of
rotifers that we know of and only around
25 of them are known to glue themselves
together into a colony
you can see this Arrangement a little
more clearly in the sinanthe arena
Colony the rotifers are all glued to
some kind of plant bound together
through the cement-like substance they
secrete from their foot they radiate
outward from there like petals on a
flower but like petals that have a crown
of cilia at their end to stir up water
and draw on food
some of these colonies are large holding
around 200 rotifers in one group others
are smaller containing only five or so
individuals connected together
and what makes rotor for colonies so
different from say bryozoa or Coral
colonies comes down to differences in
how those colonies are made let's take
rhizoa for example the process starts
with an individual brizoa larva that
attaches itself to some kind of surface
like a rock and once it's latched on
it'll split into two in a process called
budding creating a clone that can divide
again and again to produce a whole
Colony we have a whole episode on bryzoa
that you can watch if you want to know
more about how these strange looking
organisms live but the main thing you
need to know right now now is that as
these clones accumulate into a colony
their bodies are still connected in a
way that allows them to channel
nutrients to each other and coral
colonies are similar surviving as a
connected Collective of clones
[Music]
but Rota for colonies form in a few
different ways depending on the species
and none of them bear much resemblance
to the asexual budding that drives coral
and bryozoa Colony growth in some
species colonies are formed through
what's called auto-recruitive Colony
formation where a colony breaks apart
and creates multiple factions that then
grow in size as new rotifers are born
and added to the Colony then there's
what seems to us like the strangest
method some species use aloe recruitive
Colony formation where young rotifers
swim over to a sedentary adult rotifer
and stick themselves to the adult the
result can involve 50 or so young
rotifers using a grown-up as a
convenient Branch to live on and I
imagine it must be odd to go from Life
on your own to suddenly having a rotifer
daycare attached to you but maybe it all
makes sense when you're a rotiver and in
the last route called geminative Colony
formation a bunch of baby rotifers swim
to a spot and gather into a colony it
sounds simple enough but it's also my
favorite one because for some species
this process is kind of a mess
in 1906 a scientist named Frank M
surface documented how one species
creates a new colony which begins when
all the adults of a previous Colony lay
eggs it's a coordinated and carefully
timed procedure that results a few days
later in a brood of baby rotifers
connected to their parent Colony by
adhesive threads but then the mess
begins as the babies move those threads
tingle together creating a little ball
of baby rotifers they're still wriggling
and jerking around until the ball breaks
away from its Old Colony from there the
babies are on their own swimming is a
ball until they find a place to settle
down into a permanent Colony however
these colonies are formed the important
and unusual thing is they don't form in
a way that allows the rotifers to share
with each other they don't seem to be
exchanging nutrition or anything else
the way that corals and bryozoa seem to
be doing
so why
why go through all the trouble of
forming a colony
there are a few possibilities while the
rotifers may not be sharing food
gathering in these formations means that
they're all generating currents around
each other with their crown of cilia so
perhaps as scientists have considered
the joint movement of these rotifers in
this formation helps them all gather
more food or perhaps it makes them safer
a single rotifer is an easy target for a
predator but a group while conspicuous
is too big to eat making it an excellent
hiding spot for the individuals that
live within it or it could be that
there's adhesive strength in numbers as
more rotifers attach themselves to a
surface their glue reinforces each other
keeping them more securely locked in
place and less vulnerable to forces that
might sweep them away it could be any
one of these reasons or multiple of them
or perhaps something else altogether
that we haven't yet imagined whatever
the reasons they belong to the rotifer
and to the microcosmos that tumbles
around them and 50 of their closest
friends glued together at the foot
thank you for coming on this journey
with us as we explore the Unseen World
that surrounds us
since we've been talking about rotifers
this whole time we felt that it was
probably a good idea to let you know
that over at microcosmos.store you can
actually get an enamel pan of one of our
favorite rotifers the brachionus now the
brachionus is not a traditionally
Colonial rotifer but you could always
get like 20 of those pins and create
your own brachionis colony although that
might be expensive and also very heavy
to walk around with so maybe actually
you should just stick with one but we'll
leave that choice up to you whether you
want 1 or 20 brachionis pins you can
find those at microcosmos.store along
with all of our other microcosmos
merchandise
and speaking of a group of individuals
coming together the names you're seeing
on the screen right now are our
wonderful patreon patrons the people who
come together to support this Channel
and keep these videos showing up in your
subscription feed every week we can
never thank them enough and if you'd
like to join them you can sign up at
patreon.com journey to micro if you want
to see more from our master of
microscopes James Weiss and why wouldn't
you check out jam and germs on Instagram
and if you want to see more from us
there's always a subscribe button
somewhere nearby
foreign